because the index mr president
ladies and gentlemen members of the
court appointed members of the
european commission in the european council
after the vote of approval of the european parliament
i solemnly undertake to respect
the treaties and the charter of
fundamental rights  of the european union in
the execution of all my functions to
exercise my responsibilities in full
independence in the general interest of
the union in the execution of the same stages to
neither seek nor accept instructions
from any government institutions
bodies  or organizations to refrain from
any act incompatible with the nature
of my duties or the performance of my
tasks
I take note of the obligation established
by the Treaty on the Functioning of
the European Union by virtue of which
each Member State must  respect this
character and not seek to
influence the members of the commission
in the execution of their tasks
I further undertake to respect during
the  duration of my functions and after the
cessation of these the obligations
arising from my office, in particular the
duty of honesty and delicacy with
regard to the acceptance after this
cessation of certain functions or
certain advantages
[Applause]
thank you very much